welcome back
to another episode of down the middle uh
today we've got a
another treat they're all treats i call
them all treats because
i enjoy them and i hope you do too but
we have with us john mousseau he is
president ceo
and director of fixed income at
cumberland advisors
in sarasota i'm actually filming in boca
raton so we're kind of neighbors of
sorts
but more than anything else john is
known as being one of the country's
absolutely
best municipal bond fund manager he
knows the market
inside and out which is a great thing
lately uh we'll get into that but first
i'd like to uh welcome john hi
thanks danielle thanks for having me
it's great to be here um
so tell everybody a little bit about
camp coe talk because that's how we met
we met at camp kotak in the middle of
nowhere in maine
you know camp kotak which is up in
grand lake stream maine and is about two
hours north of bangor maine
and as hard as heck to get to um it
started out years ago and
and i was not at the beginning of it but
it was started out in the
probably late 90s if you will and
my first one was in 2001 but what it
really was was about
six seven eight guys that were
economists going up
fishing and talking about economics and
it went over the weekend
and it went on for a few years and then
what happened like two or three years
later maybe in
0-4 or so um
you know people from cnbc came up and
decided to uh
to film it because they had heard about
it and
steve leeson from cnbc came up with a
camera crew and
the next thing you know there are a lot
of economists that wanted to come on
this because it got a lot of play on
cnbc
so it rapidly grew from seven or eight
people up to
um a dozen 15 people and it kept going
and now it's up to about 50
plus a few others and you know we've had
bloomberg come up
uh now we stream a lot of stuff and it's
it's turned into
um it's turned into a big event and
you know last year we didn't have it
because of covid and i think a lot of
people missed it
and it is the one time a year you get to
talk to
people that you normally wouldn't talk
to right you know it's not i'm not
talking to other media bond people i'm
talking to
people that are fed experts like
yourself talking to people that are
hedge fund guys
normally don't talk to them or or women
who are hedge fund
people and the point of it is is that
what's said there stays there
and when you come out of that weekend
you come out of it with certainly more
knowledge than you went into it
whether it's applicable or not is one
thing but you're you're certainly a
better overall
uh professional for having gone i i
really i could not agree more
and um it's you you walk away with these
insights
and you're kind of forced to put away
your affirmation bias because you're
speaking to such a wide variety
of individuals and i did miss it last
year that that was terrible
um but but now we've got we're breaking
it up into two weeks there's so much
demand so
i'm counting the days it's my biggest
hall passing anything else
um okay uh getting on to more important
matters uh
how did you get i've you've never told
me this and i've never asked
how did you get the nickname of moose
well it's very short it's uh my last
name is mousseau so
um shorten that it's moose my
dad has been passed for 10 years was the
big moose he's a dentist
uh i've had three daughters they were
all called moose i had a sister and two
brothers and they were all called moose
so
when we never have our whole family
walking together i can remember walking
through
dc one day the whole family i think it
was for my graduation or something
and uh someone yells hey moose and the
whole family turns around
and that's even true with my family
today so it's hung on
it's nice to have a nickname that
everybody knows it's like cheers
so uh so your dad was a dentist what
what inspired you to
to venture into the world of finance and
portfolio management municipal bonds
it's funny because um being that he was
a
dentist and uh you know i had a
chemistry background
um in high school i always thought i'd
end up
probably not going to dental school i
always figured i'd go to medical school
and i was
well into the sciences and my senior
year of high school
i had a teacher that taught an economics
course and he happened to be the cross
country coach and i was on the cross
country team so
i was immersed with this guy for like a
year between coaching track and cross
country
and also taking an economics course
and i knew within a month of starting my
senior year taking this economics course
because this is what i wanted to do i
didn't know what i wanted to do
but i know i wanted to do something
involving economics and financial
markets
and it never stopped so i went to
college became an economics major
worked for the government got a master's
degree in economics and
filtered on down to new york well i'll
have to i'll have to share
this story with my rising senior who's
going to be an ap macro micro so it's
going to be his introduction uh
to the field for his senior year so i'll
i'll let him know
what might happen in his future it never
stops being fascinating right i mean
you look at what we went through uh this
past year
and and the the human element is
horrifying of course
but the markets element when you look at
financial markets we're in an uncharted
world
um none of us have any thing to draw
experience on to compare it to so
there's a little bit of just going on
instincts
so uh so i recently wrote about
municipal bonds for the first time in
years i had no idea that municipal bonds
were born
from the medici family uh in tuscany
and and that that was they had such
power and pull that they could get
better financing rates from the
city-states
and that spread throughout europe and
eventually in 1812
in the united states and i just i find
this to be fascinating
new york uh issued the first municipal
bond
in order to uh in order to to bridge
lake champlain and lake erie uh
to the hudson river so it was it was the
canal that was built
and that was what put the new york city
economy
on the map so um explain
um and that was followed by a series of
scandals
over the years as well um right
but for the layman can you explain what
a municipal bond is
why they exist um and and the role that
they play today
sure you know basically a municipal bond
is a certificate of indebtedness
they're issued by states counties
cities towns and the backing of those
bonds what pays the interest on those
bonds
is it a variety of revenue streams
whether they're
a pledge to pay in taxes or
their pledge to give revenues in terms
of projects think about an airport
where you have landing fees and vendor
fees etc
or a water and sewer bond where
basically anytime
someone flushes the toilet or turns on
the water the bond holder is getting
paid so
you know the security aspects of it have
differed
what has not differed uh for municipal
bonds is they have effectively
built the country that we know
over the last hundred some odd years
right and i think
that was that's what makes the
fascinating part of it
and as a professional has always been
one of the enjoyments of it because
there's very few parts of finance where
you can look at the investments
and know that they are backing not only
the schools you went to but the
hospitals you got sick in
the roads you drove over uh the water
and um you know basically sanitation
systems that you use and it goes
it goes on and on and as a professional
there's a at least for me a high degree
of satisfaction
in the fact that i'm involved in a
capital markets process
that has actually benefited the country
at large
in state and local governments in
particular um
so take us through the growth
that you've seen in the market give us
an idea of the scale
i mean i mean to compare that maybe to
the treasury market or the mortgage
market to the corporate bond market
listen you're talking about a three
trillion dollar market
um and the biggest difference
uh you know obviously not as big as the
treasury market but
the biggest difference compared to say
the corporate bond market where there's
a very fixed number of issuers right
from
from you know high grade issuers and
corporate bonds down to junk issuers
it's a fairly finite universe in
municipalities
it goes from the largest states like
california and texas
who issue billions of dollars of bonds
down to a very small
village which might be issuing a
10 million dollar bond or under
you know to finance and you know
a new new sewer lines somewhere
and the you know the old idea uh and
it's
you know it was tip o'neill the old
speaker of the house is wine
but all politics are local um that
applies to the municipal bond market
so much so because you know the
controlling part of this is that
how much to issue when to issue do we
need to do that it's all done on the
local level
right i mean that's what's refreshing
about it when you look at it
it's states cities counties
basically solving their problems
financially or it's not outside of it
but
issuing bonds to pay for things that of
course have payoffs down the road
in the growth of the city states and
counties themselves
right whether that's attracting
businesses or or
you know financing schools for their
students what have you
so that's the part that's really
different about it
um than any other thing and it has grown
remarkably
um over the last 40 years certainly
since i've been involved in the business
and it's
certainly it's certainly tied to
population but it's also tied to
the growth in where that population
grows and you've seen that
totally different in the last 40 years
and i can use
your home state of texas as an example
you know you went for years and years
with migration out of cities right so
think about the city of houston
where you moved from downtown to people
moved out past the beltway
out beyond the beltway out past the
second beltway and that was
the whole growth and if you looked at
municipal credit quality within that
confine you saw the migration
and the city's not doing as well and the
area is outside doing much better
because that's where people were
settling
et cetera then you went pre-covered
for the last 15 years going the other
way
people migrating back to city city cores
being built up when i first started
you go to houston and there's very
little going downtown at night everybody
took off
you know last 10 years there's a lot of
stuff happening downtown
and people were moving back downtown
same with other cities so as baby
boomers
kids moving into the city and baby
boomers themselves retiring and moving
back to the city
or nearby so um it has implications for
finance
has implications for for a crime it has
implications for pension funds so
for example the city of houston's
pension fund which had some drawdowns
and stuff
now as people have moved back in in much
better shape so
uh as a professional it's always
important to keep on top of those trends
um so the book was called
adventures in muniland
first of all uh
we didn't quite get to the to the to the
size of it so i'm still curious like
was it a trillion dollars 40 years ago
was it 500 billion dollars
went from a trillion to 120 trillion
okay over the last over the span of the
last 40 years so uh
what was the book about because a whole
book about municipal bonds so just
help me out here sure i mean and
you know it started
in the fact that when you
when you hit the skids in 2008 right
and again you were in uncharted waters
right we had this financial meltdown
basically caused by overhang of the
mortgage
housing market poor lending standards
etc
but the claps really
shook the financial market so you were
sitting there after lehman brothers
collapsed in the fall of 2008
in september and suddenly you had the
rush to
treasury bonds because the safety
you had to rush out of everything else
which included stocks
included corporate bonds included
municipal bots
and so suddenly you looked up and the
reason i'm going is it kind of sets the
reason for thinking about
no no please it was you looked up in
by the fall or new years of 2009
and a long treasury bond was yielding
three percent
and a long high grade tax free bond you
think about something like a yale
university was yielding you
six percent that's insane
but that's the market because it's the
psychology of the market you know and if
you didn't have an economics degree
your psychology degree would probably be
just as good
it for this kind of business is that
what was driving that it was
fear it's fear takes over um
concomitant with that was the fact that
you saw a big meltdown
in the bond insurance business uh the
the market had become akin to municipal
bond insurance and if you went back that
time period 13 years ago
about 60 of all new issues had some form
of municipal bond insurance which
basically means
if the issuer is not have the means to
pay
the bond insurer would step up and pay
um
and that business had grown and whether
you needed insurance or not
is probably an open question because i
think the last 13 years have
demonstrated you probably didn't need
that much bond insurance you needed on
some
um and certainly maybe on some lower
rated credits
but what happened to the bond insurance
business was the fact
that like any other cap property
casualty company
you know they they insure credits they
collect premiums they make money on
those premiums
the rating agencies went to the bond
insurance and said we'd like you to
diversify your book of
and not just do
they as my boss said they got out of the
shirt business and went into the shoe
business
and got their heads handed to them so
much so that
those same rating agencies that said
they would look more favorably on their
ratings if they diversified their
business
cut their ratings in some cases down to
junk what that meant is you took the
underpinnings
of the insurance away from the bond so
if you had a bond that had been insured
by a poor insurer
it now relied looking at the
underlying ratings if it was a triple b
hospital it no longer had the
aaa insurance at least in a pricing
model
this drove us to start thinking about
all the things that had gone on
in the muni business the removal of the
insurance
and then as you moved into the the awful
stance
situation that puerto rico was in uh
and you know many other cross-currents
so you had the
the meltdown in the markets the insurers
puerto rico this all happened over say
five years
and that's what led that's what led to
the book because
we looked around and nobody else had
really written a book there's letting
there's plenty of books out there
explaining about municipal bonds and how
they work and the tax exemption of
interest
but nobody had written a book about all
the things that happened
and so we did that we included many of
our writings that we put in on it
but we tried to make it pretty real time
from the financial crisis up through
early 15 when the book was published um
you know and it still sells a number of
copies today we give the
proceeds to charity it's almost time to
write another book
and high on my list to do is write a
book
uh i wouldn't necessarily call it
adventures in uni lan 2
because it sounds like a movie but um
i would like to write a book about the
bond markets and municipals in
particular
through the uh covet
so does the markets have changed so much
so before we go there
uh can you explain because it's still
going on
can you i mean a mutual friend of ours
natalie cohen
uh i ran into her uh at a at a party
in new york city years ago and
she was she she looked like she'd been
through the dryer
and she'd had the longest day and i was
what what what have you been doing all
day long it's a saturday and she said
well
i've been reading the puerto rican
constitution all day long i said what
have you been doing why are you reading
the puerto rican so what happened in
puerto rico
it's simple they issued
too much too many bonds relative to the
amount of resources that the
island had um and and i would tell you
that
the the buying community probably uh
looked past a lot of their financials um
back in the day there was a fair amount
of bonds that were insured in puerto
rico
a lot of those are still being paid by
the insurers because they happen to be
among
some the stronger insurers and
they have continued to pay and they've
started to have some settlements
but probably in the time frame that
you're talking about
which when you think about what natalie
spoke about in puerto rico
uh and i don't know whether she was
working for her own firm back then or
working for somebody else
but i'm sure what she was doing is
walking through there and saying
are we going to get paid i know because
i was doing the same thing
came to the conclusion no we're not
going to get paid but
we came to the conclusion that if you
own the insured bonds you would get paid
because the
insurance claim on a puerto rico bond
read the same as if it was
uh an insured bond for the florida
turnpike authority
so but but but what natalie described
is the same thing that every good
research person was doing
in the fall of 2008 after lehman
collapsed
they would be taking home official
statements
because they had them in paper those
days they weren't all digitized
and saying geez louise are we going to
get paid
and that's on high grade bonds i mean if
yale university is trading at six
percent
when treasury markets trading at three
the tax exempt
there's obviously market collectively
thinks there's a good chance you're not
getting paid
and and that's the nature that's the
nature of the dig down
so how how has this settled how's this
issue with puerto rico been resolved
because i still see occasional headlines
sure think about it this way
you had um not only
the meltdown and you saw this coming so
right so by
2013 in that fall
you saw the barons article and it was a
headline story about puerto rico
and like anything else headline risk is
one other risk you always deal with in
this business
and that was probably the match that lit
the fuse that started to
sell off in puerto rico debt and it
continued that fall
they brought a three and a half billion
dollar deal that following spring of 14
to try to patch up the waters uninsured
deal
it was wildly oversubscribed because it
had eight percent interest on it
um and of course
immediately within a few months those
started trading off
and you got to 2016 when they actually
stopped payment on their debt
and it it's eroded since then since then
those bonds which probably hit
you know a low point of like 25 cents on
the dollar when they stopped paying
have rebounded to probably up in the you
know 60 to 70 percent range
and why you haven't gotten paid but the
prospects of the settlement have gotten
better
as puerto ri porter and of course puerto
rico got nailed you know four years ago
with hurricane maria which set it back
more right but you have seen
involvement you've seen some private
money come in things have been rebuilt
the highway authority has been rebuilt
the power system has been rebuilt
if you go to um and and of course
stymied again by covid but prior to
covet
you saw people going back and having
uh conferences in puerto rico hotels
where
we good resort hotels were getting
filled up oh i i had a speech at the
vanderbilt i met
right it was right right before coving
right so
so you saw that you saw that firsthand
and
i think that's starting to resume and
and before that you actually saw it a
perfect example is the sales tax bonds
which
never did stop collecting revenue
because you know you spent money on
something you
collected a sales tax and it went into
the coffers what happened was the
state of puerto rico or the government
of puerto rico said
no we own that revenue slow and they
took it and stopped paying the bonds
so those bonds stop paying court cases
evolve
they're still going on that was one of
the first bonds that because it had a
cash flow to it
did they achieve settlement with bond
holders and insurers et cetera
is it are the are the settlements ideal
no the people that are
or the bondholders are begrudgingly
accepting less than 100 cents on the
dollar
because they know that's a better deal
than collecting no sense on the dollar
and and so settlements get done because
someone wants to reach a conclusion and
they don't want to be doing this 10
years from now
that's happened there it's starting to
happen now that covet is
hopefully in our rearview mirror with
other credits and we expect we expect to
see some settlements and people listen
in this country you have seen people
look at puerto rico and particularly
very um
wealthy people have started to move to
puerto rico why
because they're not paying federal taxes
in puerto rico um
because you know most people aren't
going to leave family behind and move to
puerto rico but if you have
friends there and if your family has
grown
you may say i'm going to protect you
know 40
of my income for the next few years and
moved to puerto rico and now
you know does the irs start taking a
look at that yeah maybe but right now
puerto rico is a tax haven for a lot of
people
so um let's go back to muni's 101 for
just a second um
they are tax exempt so the the the the
income that's paid the coupons that are
paid
is tax exempt can you just walk us
through just to think think of somebody
who doesn't know what a municipal bond
is
let's walk you through how that works
sure when they
the interest that they pay which makes
the bonds attractive because in a normal
world
and actually right now the levels are
normal in this sense the coupon
that is paid is exempt from federal
taxation
and in all but but not but not all but
in many cases
it's also exempt from any state taxes so
the state of california
issues a tax-free general obligation
bond or full promise to pay
you are exempt from whatever your tax
rate is on the federal level
and you're exempt from any taxes on
california level
which is at 13.3 percent
um that is a that is a big deal
particularly in high tax states
for people to try to protect their
income that is why
in most worlds not all the time not in
2008 when i described the six versus
three
but in most times that tax-free yield
is less than a treasury yield and much
less than the corporate yield
and why because you're enjoying the
benefit of the tax exemption
interestingly enough for years
and i'm not a lawyer but for years
the market always kind of
thought that the history of the tax
exemption and the ability to be
not taxed by the federal government
rested
in the separation of powers of the
constitution
and back in the 80s that was tested with
a supreme court case
that found no it's not in the separation
of powers
it's really a function of congress
congress congress is
the one who can decide whether the state
and local governments
are going to you know have to whether
they would have
whether investors would have to pay
taxes or not
and that has gone on and you know every
once in a while you see someone say
oh you know we need to make municipal
bonds taxable
it usually gets a big rise out of the uh
you know state and local government
officials lobby
who want tax exemption to remain because
the idea of building this infrastructure
we'll see whether the new infrastructure
plan includes
doses of tax-free municipal bonds with
it we haven't fleshed it out yet
but the whole point of any municipal
bond is that you want to own it
you're willing to accept the lesser
interest rate there's a
there's a a public good that's getting
financed
and the municipality most of the time
enjoys a financing rate that's less than
they would pay if they have to issue
taxable bonds
yeah i can i can recall in my in my wall
street days that
uh that the investment bankers
portfolios would be pretty darn simple
they would be
triple tax exempt new york municipal
bonds and berkshire hathaway stock
oh right so that was no it's it's you
know
it's interesting because um
you know when you get
big um debacles in the market and you
get them from one time
back in the early 80s when i started the
big debacle was the washington
public power system and
they defaulted on on debt but not all of
their debt and there was a specific
amounts that weren't defaulting because
of the way the legal decisions were
they basically built more power plants
than they needed out in the pacific
northwest
and eventually stopped painting on them
because they didn't have the growth
in people using the power that they
would need so they stopped building a
couple of plants and they went forward
on some of the other plants
the plants that were scuttled stopped
painting the debt
the ones that they were paying the debt
on they continued to pay the debt but
the prices went way down when the yields
went way up
and i can remember one of my first
projects was buying bonds
and um different portfolios of bonds
paid 13
14 12 bonds in a world where the rest of
the market was around
eight to eight to ten and i finally
found out i said
who the heck are these for those who are
berkshire hathaway
[Laughter]
small world um so
so you know sometimes we hear uh
i've studied pensions for a long time
how do public pensions
play into municipal finance
and um and separately can you
walk us through because i think this is
one of the most the least understood
aspects last year during the election
there were
all kinds of rancor and dissidents and i
remember one of the senators said
well we'll just let the state go
bankrupt um so
i think that was a fallacy so so a walk
us through the effect public
pensions have had on municipals over the
years
and and we kind of uh explain
um what the constitution has to say
about
a city's ability like detroit to declare
bankruptcy
but the state doesn't have that avenue
right that's a good point so so um
municipalities there's no such thing as
a
chapter 11. again there is chapter 9
which is a municipal bankruptcy um it it
doesn't apply to states because they're
considered
sovereign governments by themselves so
the state
who outside the state can go bankrupt
you know
really can't go bankrupt and even in the
even in the places where
and i'll work backwards on your question
even in places where you've seen some
bankruptcies so you mentioned detroit
that happened in the fall of 2014
went bankrupt or puerto rico which
basically pulled the grenade pin in the
middle of 2016
and stopped paying on their debt um
and remember there's a big difference
you can have a chapter nine
bankruptcy puerto rico just stop
painting it just
they just stopped painting that's just a
straight out default they just default
right
so there's a big distinction between
having a bankruptcy and just defaulting
in a chapter 9 bankruptcy you basically
have to say i have done everything
in my power to pay off my creditors
um in the case of detroit you know they
went and said hey we have
this much in pension expenses uh we have
all these
you know other expenses here's our
revenue stream
they don't match we knew that we need
the relief of
bankruptcy to do this it is a very hard
thing to
to do which is why even last year when
someone was talking about oh you know
they talk about state of illinois or
new jersey who have been kind of the
poster children for bad state
governments for the last few years the
state of new jersey
which is a you know i lived there for
many years
it has lots of resources at its disposal
what it has is a
pension fund which has a lot of expenses
et cetera um
if you were actually to go and say hey
um
we're not we're not doing a chapter nine
but if you could do a chapter nine
if you could have a state do a chapter
nine you would have to go up there and
say
we have we have done everything in the
world to try to um
satisfy our expenses and and sell stuff
well you could sell the new jersey
turnpike authority which is statements
you could sell the garden state parkway
you could you could sell off a lot of
office buildings
you could sell off parks that the state
owns and sell them to developers there's
lots of things you can do
but they're not doing it so boil it down
to a city like detroit
there's lots of arguments there i i
would say as a as
not a bondholder because we didn't own
them but if you looked at it you'd say
oh someone said hey the detroit the
detroit
you know art museum has tons of fine art
they could sell to
satisfy some of their debts judge said
no they don't have to do that because
that's really hurting the spirit of the
city etc
i don't know it's an asset like anything
else um you know they didn't sell office
buildings so
what what happens is and this is why
credit analysis is so important
is in the end
most municipal judges are going to say
to sell off these assets which they
should do
legally to satisfy their debts they
don't want to make them do
because it puts the city so far behind
the eight ball and trying to regrow
itself
post bankruptcy which is why some of
this stuff goes forward
the lesson in that story is you have to
be careful as a general obligation
bondholder because
even though the legal documents say you
have the right to all of their
sources and they would have to sell
stuff to pay you
in the end you're just another unsecured
creditor because
in practicality you're not paid to
heading into what you said about
pensions
pensions have been a big issue
over the years right um
the problem with the municipal pensions
in general
is that the people that are deciding
them who are the officials in the
state or city governments they do a lot
of
you know generous pension benefits
they're not around to see the mistakes
that they've made down the road because
they're out of office or voted out of
office or retire from office
so they make those decisions when you
look
at some of the pensions they're not
picking on
any particular one but there's a plenty
of horror stories on there
of you know people retiring and their
their pay is
is either a function of their last year
of pay
or it is their last year of pay going on
forever i mean
the the and the pension issues are
obviously in certain cities and states
and they're they're big and
part of it has also been hey we have
generous pensions
because municipal employees are paid
less than they would get in private
industry
and there's a there's a there's an
aspect to that that's that's true
but the runoff when you look at some of
the
um the things that are promised is crazy
now the management of those pension
funds
is far from you know
perfect either and that's been part of
it i mean if you went back to the late
1990s and if you remember the tech
bubble
back then and things were um
really doing well on the you know stock
market side
you had a fair amount of you had a fair
amount of state pension funds
not all but some that went down
and looked and with the run-up in the
stock market et cetera their pensions
were fully funded
this is only going back 22 years ago
fully funded
actually more than fully funded they had
a surplus
so and not being a pension expert i can
tell you though
if you get to a point where you're at a
surplus you've won
you've won the ball game it's time to
take some of that surplus away
and lock it up because you've won
in other words don't don't let things
erode
and what happened in some of these
states they doubled down
they issued pension obligation bonds in
other words
bonds that were backed full general
full faith and credit of the states
and they took that money and reinvested
in the stock market
we know what happened to the tech
business and the
confounding thing about it is if they
had taken the surplus or even more
they could have bought 10-year us
treasury bonds at six percent back then
and locked it up or or some higher grade
corporates up to seven
and and the point of it is they went
just the opposite
and doubled down and you know
what what you really wonder about is
where the heck were the actuaries
at those times passing muster on stuff
and listen you know that's that's that's
an issue they are paying the price for
that
even today because even with the
rebounds in the stock markets and things
we've seen
we know that we had the meltdown in the
tech stock
tech market but we also had this
unlimited
seemingly unlimited growth in pension
benefits being paid out
and it continues to be a problem for
this day
um most municipalities have come through
the covent pretty well
um and so net net even some of the
states that were in trouble look better
today financially than they did
before covet why most states can
thank the supreme court for the wayfarer
decision a few years ago
which allowed states to collect sales
taxes
at the point of sale which is their
citizens
regardless of who's selling what
wherever they're selling it from
um that made a magnificent difference in
flow of funds to many states that is why
for a large reason the state of
california
for all the turmoil that it had on the
human side with covid
on the financial side benefited from
everyone staying at home
buying stuff on the internet and
collecting sales tax
and on top of the capital gains in the
stock market and the fact that incomes
are going up in the tech area et cetera
california looks down and sees a 15
billion dollar surplus
so my thought is that governor newsom if
he
can beat back this uh recall that people
are trying to do
i think his next order of business would
be to make sure the legislature doesn't
go and spend that surplus and
try to put part of it into a rainy day
fund we'll see
if jerry brown was still the governor
that's what he'd be pushing
um so let's let's step back from you
from the municipal market uh
for a minute and and and give me your 40
000 feet above the air view on the big
question of whether
debt and deficits matter
they matter if you take the longer view
right so in other words think about the
us
we've been able to finance our way
through a lot of this
uh what has really helped this
country do that one like other places
we're a reserve currency right so people
will accept our
our debt and hep so
we just issue and their their promises
to pay
um you know not like the old days when
the dollar was backed by gold
the interest on that that has been
in terms of the interest cost has been
fairly benign because so much of it has
been short-term
and we know short-term rates have been
low fairly low for a fairly long period
of time
so you have two components there you
have the interest expense
and the the main point as we know is
that the interest expense as a
percentage of the gdp in this country
has been low i think and
not just this administration but you go
back to the last administration in the
white house
the trump administration almost
everything that you saw come out of this
and i would put this infrastructure bill
in the same
category depending on how it gets
fleshed out
is to is to spur on growth
because if interest rates rise
that expense of the debt starts to
become
larger but if the economy is growing as
a percentage of the economy it doesn't
become the thorn in the economy
if the economy is not growing but that
interest expense
continues to grow because short-term
interest rates are rising
that interest expense starts to serve as
a wet blanket on the economy and holds
things back
the other thing that can hold things
back is like what if some of our
larger partners around the world decided
they didn't want to
own u.s debt um
you know my guts tell me that doesn't
happen because if they
caused an event that would cause
interest rates to go up sharply that
would reduce the value of all the debt
that they're continuing to hold
but you know that relies on the politics
that are in these countries too and we
know
we know that can change we see we see it
in china right now
between the the forces at work
of the existing government but also the
fomenting of human rights that we've
seen in hong kong et cetera
who knows what the government's going to
look like in 10 years may look vastly
different
they may have a different attitude
towards that that's why i'm saying if
you take the long view on this stuff
you'd like to see you know
some reduction in the amount of deficits
here
you know if you if you look at this
country and you look at it at a broad
uh level and our friend jim bianco has
great charts on this
you can look and see big government
deficits like world war
ii hey our deficit in covid which we
spent unlimited amount of money on it
seemed
right still was a percentage of gdp
wasn't as big as it was during world war
ii
that deficit which was markedly down
was markedly large started to
go away as you get into the late 40s and
the economy was booming right
and by the way we had some pretty big
inflation numbers back in the mid to
late 40s
that doesn't get written about quite a
bit and that's because what happened all
the soldiers were home
uh you know they're looking for housing
uh
all the things that were rationed during
the war uh
gasoline uh rubber certain foods et
cetera we're in big demand
uh there's some echoes of that right now
going on by the way
um from an inflation standpoint but what
happened is the economy boomed
taxes were collected and back then the
attitude was we didn't want to do
that much deficit financing so the
country you know went to surpluses
then we went to deficits in the vietnam
war back to a surplus during clinton and
it's really since 9 11
and what we've spent we've been in
various modes of
deficit financing ever since the economy
has done very well so a lot of people
would say oh the economies have done
well we can just
we can just run this out forever
um our kids my kids a little older than
your kids but our kids are going to have
this issue down the road to deal with
and the idea that you're just going to
continue to roll this up
is the fact that i'm old the the
economics that i
learned wouldn't allow that to go on
forever
well you so you you let the inflation
genie out of the bottle
uh where where where are you on this uh
you know it was interesting
we got fresh uh fresh data out on uh
personal spending and adjust it for
inflation it was down 0.4 percent
uh which was a little surprising uh that
was four times worse than what the
estimate was
and we we're seeing the saving uh rates
start to come down
we've also seen fed data that show that
the vast majority of the 1.2 trillion
dollars in
savings that was built up is in the
hands of people 65 years and older
so um so but that is a backdrop if you
will
uh where do you see this inflation
debate headed
i i see it continuing i think it has to
run out you know we have the the
argument and believe me
at cumberland advises we have this
argument in-house all the time
um the question is is that
in the fed's views transitory which is a
pretty fancy fancy word for temporary is
it transitory
inflation and does it start coming back
down
and if you look and depend it doesn't
matter whether you want to use pce which
was
a little higher by a tenth today than
expectations
or you want to do cpi or ppi take your
pay
and you say okay it's higher
and remember we don't care we don't care
about
year over year numbers because we know
that
if we go back and take away last year
2020 march
april may which were like zero negative
one negative or
negative point one negative point five
whatever the numbers were they were all
zero to negative numbers
you're replacing them with positive
numbers now so by definition those
year-over-year numbers are growing and
the market knows that and the market is
discounted
what the market doesn't know is what's
going to be the month over month over
month over month numbers as we go
forward here and like a lot of places i
can tell you people that
in certain business roundtables i'm in
here the biggest problem is
getting labor so you know
for for entry-level jobs that might be
laboring jobs for
developments or people putting additions
on houses
people working in restaurants people
working uh
at resorts used to be in florida you
know starting
salaries wages were like 13 to 15 an
hour now they're paying 17 to 21
an hour and by the way if the workers
are there a week they're giving them a
raise
to keep them i heard a story last week a
guy brought in two cooks they did a good
job for two weeks
so we have to go use the restroom didn't
come back
so it's that what's going on
that gets embedded right so so if you're
if you're sitting there buying lumber
and it's gone sky high
we already know that lumber's come down
a third and um
i wish i knew who said this because i've
heard my boss david say but i don't
think it was his phrase but the best
cure for high prices
is high prices and those those things
tend to self-cure
as supply comes out wage wage increases
don't come down or don't come or they
come down very slowly
and what i'm worried about
is you know how long does the market
accept a one and a half percent ten-year
bond
as you continue to print higher monthly
numbers if those numbers come back down
because remember for years
if you went back years the core cpi
number that came out and we can argue
which inflation number to use but i
i like that one it's always been free
for
months and months and months it was
point one or point two you had a couple
of months a point two you had a couple
months a point one
the net of it all is that you were
always somewhere around two
a little below a little above and
you'd been there and and bond market
yields would fluctuate of course
with with some of the projections for
growth going forward if the economy
looked like it was doing better their
brightness a little higher the look that
was softening their
heels a little lower but didn't change a
heck of a lot was
the cpi numbers the core cpi numbers
now they have changed and moved forward
so now you're printing
you printed a 0.9 you know that doesn't
last but then you print a 0.6 then you
create a 0.7
then you print another 0.6
if you're if your reduction comes down
and the run rate tends to be
0.4 or 0.5 or 0.3 or 0.4
as opposed to the 0.6 and 7 that you're
printing now
but not goes back to the 0.1 or 0.2
now you're now you're talking about a
run rate of inflation when you get there
that's going to be somewhere between
three and a half to five or three and a
half to four and a half
how long does the 10-year bond stay at
one and a half when you're doing that
it can stay below the rate of inflation
for a long time
if you go back and look at the 70s when
inflation really got the hell out of
control
you had periods of time in the early 70s
or recall the mid 70s
where inflation was well above
the 10-year bond yield but then came
back down it almost it almost
looked like a giant hump and the 10-year
bond yields did the same
the bond markets became self-learning a
little more
and the next time inflation moved up
bond yields started to move up
and then inflation moved even higher
and it took a little while it's like oh
god they can't stay this high for that
long
but they did and then the bonnies took
yet another leap up as we got to the
late 70s and early 80s
and then inflation as we know when
paul volcker took over started to come
down why because he's raised a hell out
of interest rates and the bond markets
took the cue from that
and bond yields stay much higher than
inflation
for at least another seven or eight
years until they believed that inflation
was actually
on the decline in debt so
it's a long-winded way of saying is i
don't know for sure
but the run rate the run rate of
inflation as we go out
forward is going to be is going to be
really important
uh you mentioned you know the basically
in another way the money supply that's
out there
which has come down a little bit right
and if the margins come down and may be
responsible for some of the
decline that we've seen in that 10-year
bond yield going from 175 down to this
150ish level
but it's still there and what we don't
know
is we don't know what the turnover of
money is so you
because you're still in this period of
time where
we're just coming out and we're
experimenting not experimenting we're
seeing the turnover of money
pick up and how much does it pick up and
how much of it
is that a cause of inflation in the
price level the old
irving fisher idea which i happen to
believe so you think about
now you're gonna you're now you're gonna
um look at att stadium in dallas this
fall
filled with people for the first time in
a couple years
that's that's not last year was just the
cowboys playing in there with only a few
fans
this is now full ticket revenue
concession revenue parking revenue and
that money gets turned over and that
money gets turned over to other people
and gets respect and that gets respect
and you can replace that example
with a cruise ship out of miami you can
replace it with a convention center in
las vegas
you can replace it with dorms of
colleges filled with students this fall
and the analogy is the same
so i don't think we know what
the money supply which has been
skyrocketed but is declining
how that combines with a turnover of
money
which has been low and we know it's
going to pick up and probably pick up
even more
so um in the in the interim we've got
this
this this debt limit debt limit
negotiations that are going to be going
on
um which kind of takes you back to 2011
given given it looks like uh i think
somebody on my twitter feed today said
that
mitch mcconnell would give give a kidney
uh in order to
in order to get the gavel back and we
know that it's going to be very
rancorous and a very hot
summer um but we also know that the
country has more
money on hand than it normally would
heading into a situation like this janet
yellen has
has a bigger cushion uh right but but
what are your expectations for this and
how it affects the economy
i i think and i i
agree with your your assessment of uh
senator mcconnell i think he'd love to
be back in the driver's seat
um i think as you go towards the 2022
elections
with the exception of the more left
part of the democratic party i think
most people are going to be looking at
as people come out of the hibernations
and are back working back in their
office
some of the traditional views come to go
forward if you're sitting there at home
and you're out of a job you want all the
money spent in the world right if you're
back working in a job
you may say you know jesus louise i
don't want to see my taxes go up a
gazillion
i want to see maybe a little less
spending et cetera
so as you had the 2022 election i would
say
on average the person running democrat
or republican doesn't want to be seen as
a person
that wants to be on the last spending
spree so i think what
president biden gets out of this package
with the infrastructure and any other
spending
i think i don't want to say it's the
last hurrah of the administration
i think it's certainly the last hurrah
before the 2022 elections
and i think that's going to have a
dampening effect and listen
you know as we all know it seems like
when you have an election
the next order of business is how to win
the next election and
i do think there's a fair amount of
of i don't say conservative but but
less liberal democrats that want to join
to find a solution i mean this this
bipartisan group of 10 senators
i mean i was thrilled to see it because
you know anytime you see
cooperation i'm like yes boy that was
whatever your political stance we can
all argue that was truly lacking in the
last
administration for better or for worse
um the fact that vice president harris
just invited all the women senators
regardless of party to her house
i said yay that's great because i mean
you know when we were growing up
or certainly when i was a little older
is that you had this
you had this spirit of cooperation and i
truly believe that a lot of it
is based on the fact that our parents
only knew three networks of network news
and you had basically more or less
nbc in the middle cbs was a little more
liberal abc was a little more
conservative
but you were never far outside the
center and since then between the growth
of the internet
satellite radio um
blogs etc the extremes have had so much
foment to them that you've pushed the
middle so far out and you have what we
have had
so i i believe in reversion of the mean
and everything
and i think it's in politics too so i
i'd like to think that you see some
level of cooperation there and i for
for a president that spends so much time
in office himself and still knows a lot
of the senators that are in office some
of the older senators
from his time is either vice president i
think he's
geared up towards some cooperation on
here too so i think you'll see it i
think you'll see
even a different white house in 2022.
um so uh reversion to the mean
um you you started out at ef hutton
you know when you're cutting talks
people listen blah blah blah i mean that
that that quote
back a ways um but we have seen a real
uptick in retail participation in in the
stock market
uh about 25 right now and i'm wondering
what your views are if you can take off
your
bond hat for a minute and put on your
your stock hat for me do you
do you think we go back to valuations do
you think valuations in the stock market
will
also revert to the mean yeah
i think things happen over that i mean
certainly valuations if you're talking
about
um things like pe ratios and
other traditional things that i don't
want to say have been thrown out the
window but
you know you think about where you were
right and i'm
i'm simplifying this somewhat but
if you think going all the way back last
year if you went back to the
summer of last summer august you had the
10-year bond at half a percent
so if you're using that or something off
of that as your
discount rate and you have earnings
from a lot of tech companies growing at
double digit rates so far far far
exceeding the any amount of rate you're
doing at discounting
you you you get this so somebody in in
august of 2020 said
boy you know it's half a percent of the
10-year bond i can go buy the nasdaq 100
and it's price is high but you know what
that's yielding me half a percent
so um just maybe just maybe in the next
10 years
i will get you know some growth
appreciation
in those hundred companies and i'll
still get the same yield as i got on the
10-year bot
now as soon as you made that judgment
you immediately got about an eight
percent correction in the
in the next deck so you'd say boy did i
do the right thing but if you hung on
you've done well
we know that stocks over time do do well
and and regardless of the calamity they
come back because
of the growth in the economy and and the
fact that the country grows by the way
the one of the best things about our
country versus other countries is even
though our
our population growth rate is very small
it's better than anybody else's and that
that helps over time too i do think
though there's this
reversion to the mean you know you
talked about the retail investor
um we always hear that that you know
main street doesn't participate
in the equity markets like wall street
does right
and and that this growth doesn't mean
that much i think that's changed a
little bit at the margin and you do have
more retail participation
does the average american when they're
back at work have the time to trade
stocks
you know i think maybe it means maybe a
little more for managed money
maybe people say you know i don't have
the time to do this i'm at the desk and
i don't have time to
i don't have time to log on to my schwab
account every other minute and
trade something i'm going to have to
i'm going to have to do this because i
do believe you'll see some more
continued working at home but i think at
the margin people do
float back into the office so i just i
just think
that this return to normal also probably
means some return to normalcy
in in valuations i mean
i'm not the equity guy how many more
subscribers does a netflix
have on when people are back working how
about people going to conferences
that's more in other words the things we
had as normal
were all subtracted from our time of day
they're going to be added back into our
time of day maybe not at the rate that
we did that but that's
including some business travel that's
including going to some conferences
that's including doing um training at
work
that probably hasn't happened you know
maybe it's happened by zoom but
um so that's that's the way i think i
just think i don't think that's
necessarily a warning bell for the stock
market
because i think the stock market could
do very well with
slightly higher interest rates over time
remember it's not it's not the fact that
you'd have higher interest rates
is the speed at which you would get the
higher interest rates
um so so winding down here i'm curious
because we've had this massive
flight to the exurbs and boise idahos
hot
and so this this trend was pretty
amazing to see
you know this flight out of urban
centers
but you know you're seeing headlines
that say you know the cities are
starting to come back
so what do you think the municipal bond
market's gonna is
is it gonna be a more balanced market
than we've seen for a generation
i think it's gonna kind of go back to
where we were slowly over time you made
a great point and
i think i saw the same cbs piece on
boise that you did
and it was remarkable this gal sold her
house for a
heck of a lot more money than she
thought she would and
got a deal where she could live in it
for another six months before they took
it over so you know the sellers control
everything
um you've seen that even in the big
centers like
you know new york and boston et cetera
so
for years in in the new jersey area
where i used to live so i
know a little about it if you went back
25 years ago you saw
a lot of people leave not just the city
but also the the train line suburbs
right where you could even get easy
access to the city
they were leaving and they were moving
out god
50 60 miles out and they weren't moving
in big mansions they were moving to
mansions you didn't i mean these are
wealthy people but you
you didn't see your neighbors you had
all these you know developments where
you know acres and acres you know for
each house and all this and that was the
hot item
jump ahead to the ten years or
seven or eight years certainly
pre-covered
and what was that trend is we talked
about it before with houston
that was people wanting to come back to
the cities that was the growth of the
cities that was people's kids going to
the city i want to be closer to my kids
i mean
i'm retired or i don't have anything at
home i'll move to the city it's that
idea
and that happened and you couldn't give
away those
big mansions for about six or seven
years and we heard stories
of people that bought stuff in the late
90s
for two to three million and we're
letting
them go for like a million to a million
and a half think about that trade for a
minute
over 20 years 20 plus years you were
losing
40 to 50 on a house
and not even counting what you've lost
to inflation so
that's a remarkable that's a remarkable
trade by the way
that trade undid itself in all of two
months and everybody wanted to be
back out where i don't see my neighbors
i have an office
and stuff so whether you're sitting in
the hills outside in new jersey or
sitting in montauk long island
or up in the catskills from a new york
standpoint
someone says boy i've got all i need to
do
i can work here i'm not going back into
the city for years
maybe not the rest of my life you know
or just a few times a year
if i have to i think that changes
when you're sitting out in those places
and suddenly a deal gets done and we
know these firms are going back and
i mean when a deal gets done that you're
not part of
and this can be at a brokerage firm this
could be at a bank this could be at an
architecture firm
this could be anywhere consulting
something happens
and you're not a part of it because
you're not back in the office
i think the next thing you say is i got
to get myself an apartment in the city
or do something because i've got to be
back in
somewhat regularly and i think you've
seen that
just in new york city because you have
now gone through six months in a row
of rising co-op prices
not back to pre-covet but rising from
the 30 percent down where they were
and rents and i can tell you this just
from my oldest daughter
spent the week spent the winter in
vermont
skiing and working remotely and doing
working very hard remotely
but was moving back into new york and
got an apartment and i said you need to
you need to give up a weekend of skiing
and get back
and get an apartment because you'll
never get the deals
in the spring that you're going to get
in january or february
well they came back in may and got it
and basically got a nice apartment and
pre-covered rent
um and didn't get any deal that tells
you something
that tells you that markets are
responding
to people i i heard plenty of vulture
people trying to buy
you know five million dollar apartments
for you know throwing bids out for three
million to see whether they could get a
counter
um that type of that type of stuff and i
think
but i think at the margin people want to
be back
at cities look most businesses and the
investment management business is the
perfect example
are apprenticeship type businesses we
have
we have survived because of technology
over the last year and a half and it's
been good and firms have done well
why have we done well our expenses have
been lower it's it's it's very simple on
that that's right
and our revenues have stayed the same or
gotten a little better
for a while now you're going to want to
have people back
and yes you know at the beginning your
revenues will grow but your expenses
will might grow
a little more as people come back but
what you haven't had
at least in my opinion is the ability of
people
and professionals to grow because you
know
helen is sitting next to joe and
learning
you know this kind of portfolio
management that's been more treading
water for the last year
and and people's professional skills and
and professional growth
will now start to increase again and
that's a that's a productivity
i think that's a another productivity
thing coming on top of
everything that we've learned from zoom
so um
one last question so if if cities are
coming back john
um i'm we're going to flash a graph
up on the screen here but if cities are
coming back
this is important because we talk about
this subject often
can we bring baseball back because
viewer attendance at baseball games is
just in the
it's been slumping for years but i'm
kind of hoping you can give us some
some insights about what the future of
baseball in america is
well there's a there's a rebound factor
right as you come out of the economy so
go look at look
go look at um the texas rangers
uh stadium right so
we'll pick on your hometown now they
sold out their first games but they
continue to have very good numbers
why because when baseball started they
never put restrictions
on people going let's counter that with
the tampa bay rays who are here who have
an indoor stadium so they're
they're uber careful and stuff so i
share some tickets with some people i
went to some games in april
not too many people there and most of
the city you know you got to sit down
and most of the seats were you know with
like
almost chain like twist ties and just
cut off
i went to the game the other night
versus the red sox i'm not telling you
that it was crowded
but it was four or five times as many
fans there
now in june as there was in april
um the the the traditional
places where fans attendance is an issue
will continue to be an issue that's
regardless of comet
that's the quality of the team that's
the marketing of baseball
um i can tell you if you want to go see
a game in fenway park
and you don't have access to tickets
you're going to pay a couple hundred
bucks a ticket through a broker because
that's the demand
that there is in boston to go see the
red sox some of that pent up certainly
but you know the red flags are doing
fine beforehand trying to go to games so
i don't think i can tell socks yankees
yeah and the yankees and the yankees and
the mets will be the same way
i i do think look at does baseball think
they have a
a problem with a a time being too long
in the game
certainly that's one of the reasons you
see the the guy in second base and
starts out an extra inning
that's why you see a stopwatch on the
pitchers they can't take that much time
they have i think 30 seconds between
pitches
um it's all to speed up the game so you
don't hear
michael k of the yankees say at the end
of the game and the final score is this
and in an interminable four hours and 14
minutes
and i think and i think you know you
want to have a low three handle on that
and and that's that's really how they
i don't think you have to rebuild
baseball you have to tweak it a little
bit because uh
you know at the margin is still a great
game awesome
all right well uh i look forward to
grand lake's stream
um and it was great uh great visiting
with you john i can't wait to see you in
person
uh take care and thanks so much for
sharing your insights today
really appreciate thanks daniel i
appreciate it a lot see you okay
bye-bye well everybody uh thanks so much
uh for sticking around watching me and
john mu show
musso excuse me shoot the breeze uh
i i hope you enjoyed it study up on
municipal bonds if you don't know them
uh
the the market has absolutely been on
fire
in a post-covered world there's a lot of
concerns that our taxes might be going
up
uh so if you're a young investor it's
definitely an area that you should be
looking into
going forward if you liked my discussion
with moose
as his friends call him then you would
also enjoy
a recent episode of down the middle with
christopher cole of artemis capital
so give that a watch if you missed it
and i look forward to the next time if
you haven't subscribed please do so
and i will see you next time around
thanks so much